they only know like two villains maybe
venom whoa
smart I think venomous
[Music]
who are you in this vast multiverse
who are you in this vast multiverse so
we need to talk about spider-man far
from home
the third spider-man film and what's
happening between these two Avengers
films so if you're finding me for the
first time be sure to subscribe to get
all the Marvel videos we're just getting
started there's a new round of that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway going on
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on the
video I'll be sure to name a winner at
the end of this but you all probably
know by now that far from home is gonna
be a globe-hopping adventure Mysterio is
gonna be the main villain they're still
trying to lock down jake gyllenhaal
Mysterio is the character Jake
Gyllenhaal is just the one thing that
they haven't confirmed yet Kevin Feige
is like we're working on it we're almost
there they don't need him to start
shooting the movie there's so many
different things that you could shoot
with just a couple of the characters hey
guys just say thank you for coming today
I'm I wish I could come out and see you
but I'm not allowed but thank you so
much for coming you guys are amazing
just hanging out in the Sun but as
you've seen from all the funny Kevin
Feige interviews with Amy Pascal venom
is supposed to exist over by itself in
the Sony spider-verse adjacent to the
MCU based on Kevin Feige G's reaction
and I'll include that clip in a second
it seems like he doesn't want to deal
with spider-verse stuff right now while
they're closing down this first big era
of Marvel films well those movies will
all take place in the world that we are
now creating for for you know for Peter
Parker I mean it'll they'll be adjuncts
to it they may be different locations
but it will still all be in the same
world and they will be connected to each
other as well so there is a chance that
and tom hollander spider-man will pop up
somewhere that's always if you ever want
to see what Kevin Feige looks like when
he gets triggered that's it so assuming
that venom is meant to be in a separate
universe in that the Sony spin-off films
like they just announced the silk film
for instance there's a silk character in
spider-man homecoming Cyndi moon is even
supposed to be on the bus here and this
infinity war scene it's just that the
way they shoot it from this angle you
can't see all the people that are
actually sitting on the bus so if
they're gonna do a silk movie and they
already have a character in the MCU I
think that's more evidence that it's
supposed to be a separate universe but
what are they doing with
the animated film right now they're
literally doing into the spider-verse
with all the different versions of Peter
Parker as well as the different versions
of spider-man or spider-gwen in the
instance of Gwen Stacy so like you have
multiple Peter Parker's but you also
have the other versions of spider-man
popping up they'll be taking that film
to comic-con I'll do a video about it
when they post a new trailer but we'll
learn more about what's going on with
that soon obviously the animated films
are not in the same continuity as the
live-action films so the easiest way to
do venom crossover with spider-man in
the future film is to do a version of
live-action spider-verse but what Kevin
Feige and the MCU has been doing is
cultivating the sinister six as
characters slowly building up towards a
bigger and bigger film by the time you
get to whatever the third spider-man
film is going to be we know it'll
probably have home in the title because
you do spider-man homecoming spider-man
far from home you can start guessing
with the title of the third film is
going to be but because we haven't had
Norman Osborn yet and Mysterio is
supposed to be the big villain of
spider-man 2 it just sounds like we're
building towards big sinister six
team-up in that third film so short term
that's why I think that they're just
letting venom off to do his own thing so
in success Tom Hardy will continue to
play the character they'll do a sequel
they'll do crossovers with the Morbius
film that Jared Leto is going to be in
that's right Jared Leto is going to be
Morbius the vampire for Sony
spider-verse
then you can push into the idea of the
actual spider-verse have Tom Holland in
a much simpler way just crossover into
different dimensions without doing
full-blown inheritors more lund
spider-verse
so if you're not a big comic book reader
spider-verse is a very messy story is
this big saga about Merlin stealing the
power from totems and it's sort of a
different way of explaining how
spider-man's powers work probably not
something that Kevin Feige wants to deal
with because it gets to this infinity
war level of craziness and they just did
that so they probably don't want to do
that with the spider-man character
within the MCU but they're content to
let the animated films get as crazy as
they want so a live-action spider-verse
would have to be a much simpler version
they probably wouldn't do more Lund they
would probably stick with the sinister
six because that's what they're building
towards so it just becomes a much easier
way to explain watching that venom
trailer how the symbiotes get to play
earth you know you can do all these
derivatives spider-man characters
without having Tom Holland be a main
character in all the films you could
just tell whatever backstory that you
want but just like that Doctor Strange
clip just like we've seen an infinity
war dr. strange looking through
different timelines Avengers 4 in the
rumors about them going between
different dimensions to alternate
universes to get the gems and assemble
the gauntlet that way just at a
conceptual level think about the way
Marvel deals with big concepts like that
and how they would handle a version of
the spider verse you tease the idea of a
multiverse in a Doctor Strange movie
then you deep dive into that during
infinity war and Avengers 4 then once
everybody on the planet watches those
movies they understand the concept of
alternate versions of the characters
existing in alternate realities so it's
much easier for them to buy a
spider-verse movie where you see
characters from alternate dimensions so
it becomes much easier to explain how
venom appears in a spider-man movie with
Tom Holland but you've never seen him
before in this reality like how come we
haven't seen him before alternate
universe BAM that's how you do it but
what about timeline when would they
actually be able to do something like
that because I'm pretty sure that we're
not gonna see any kind of venom in
spider-man far from home and we're not
gonna see symbiote with Tom Holland in
Avengers 4 maybe a couple references
that will merit more videos later when
we get more information about the actual
plot of Avengers 4 so just open up a
bookmark for that right now I think all
evidence points towards no symbiote in
Avengers 4 we get spider-man 2 next year
that's 2019 then two years after that we
get the next spider-man film whatever
number three is going to be called then
by the time Marvel and Sony rework
whatever their new sharing arrangement
is going to be they talk about potential
crossover with the spider verse and
that's where you get to your venom
crossover so it would be at least five
or six years away so all of that is just
built on success so if the venom movie
does well people like it Tom Hardy will
come back and do a sequel and Kevin
Feige will probably be more open to
allowing that character within the MCU
if it's not successful Sony doesn't make
a sequel Kevin Feige never has to think
about him again so he's like okay you
know maybe someday we'll get to venom
and that sundae just turns into 10 or 12
years
I think Marvel has spent so much time
cultivating the universe that it has now
and it's getting ready to break that and
reform it in Avengers for that I don't
think that they want to deal with Sony
spider-verse anytime soon like it's
already complicated enough it's a lot
easier for someone like Kevin Feige that
controls all the money to take the
wait-and-see approach
oh it's successful okay people like this
character will let him crossover with
our beloved spider-man but just remember
I think all that will come after we get
a version of the sinister six
within the MCU and I don't think that
that's going to happen to the third
spider-man film I think Mysterio and
spider-man far from home is just the
next step on the ladder to sinister six
like they're slowly ramping up towards
Norman Osborn Green Goblin most of what
we know of Sony's version of venom is
that he's a little bit lethal protector
a little bit planted to the symbiotes
and it's a little bit agent venom but
with the Eddie Brock character instead
of Flash Thompson and even though we
have Miles Morales in the cartoons for
those of you asking about him in the MCU
I'm not expecting him during far from
home either
maybe they'll tease him but not as
spider-man during the third spider-man
film just to be determined I'll do more
videos if we get more information about
that leave all your video requests in
the comments below
congratulations - Omar Z please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here to rewatch that funny
spider-man 2 teaser and click here to
learn all about the Avengers 4 title
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]